the fourth of july is just three days
away but according to a brand new fox
news poll pride in america is now
plummeting under joe biden gee i wonder
why just 39 percent of voters are proud
of the country including just 46 percent
of democrats joining us now with
reaction is the first green beret to be
elected to congress representative
michael waltz michael thank you so much
you know people can look at a a poll
like that and and think like that we do
we don't like the country it's not that
we because we love the country
we don't like
what's happening to it and how we're
being represented is that your take on
this
yeah tammy i think that's part of it but
i think there's something more
fundamental here because if you look at
the polling data you see a steady
decline over the last uh decade plus and
i point to our education system and
covet exposed to us the garbage that's
being taught in our schools great point
and we have things being taught in our
schools that this is a fundamentally bad
country that at its core it is
misogynist it's racist it's colonialist
it wasn't founded to establish
individual freedom for we the people
away from monarchies and emperors that
it actually was established to protect
slavery when that's being taught in our
schools and then on top of that you have
things even in like math class which we
discovered in florida word problems in
math class that talk about counting the
numbers of oppressors and oppressed and
now in our military
they're sending you they're saying on
the one hand you need to be willing to
go die for our constitution and our flag
but it is fundamentally on its core bad
and flawed uh i think you take all of
that together uh and when you talk about
a military as this president has and the
secretary of defense has that's overrun
with white supremacy it doesn't surprise
me you're seeing this kind of decline uh
in in pride and in our institutions and
pride in our flag yeah and you know i
think that there is a combination of
things going on i think it's that that's
an excellent point that we have young
people especially being indoctrinated
with loathing the country uh and they
don't know because history's not taught
anymore right they don't have much of a
background but i do think that we know
that a good majority of americans know
that what you described
is a result of policy it's this is not
this is not a natural organic thing
that's going on that this is a group of
people running the country
that have done this to us is is there on
this fourth of july you know there's
even
you know this sense that the fourth of
july might become a partisan holiday do
you envision that happening
you know i i pray not and i'm going to
do everything i can to fight and remind
people uh that this flag
that stands for individual liberty the
right to assemble the right to free
speech the right to criticize your own
government and that there are
literally uh more people out right now
more military members out right now
willing to die for that flag right than
the entire canadian and and australian
armies combined but yeah tammy you know
who does appreciate this country and is
literally dying to get here those are
immigrants like the afghans that were so
desperate to come to this great nation
they were willing to cling to the side
of a jet yeah or the people dying coming
across our southern border but to your
point it's all self-inflicted wounds and
if you look at where we were the month
before the pandemic hit with record
unemployment across every ethnic sector
black white and brown women and men uh
with a roaring economy with justice
reform tax reform middle east peace if
you look at where we were under the
previous administration and people
looked at the results in their lives
they were pretty
excited and now they look at everyday
problems and they're only compounding it
and right yeah i mean this is it and we
have to remember i think that the the
debacle of afghanistan
is what kind of shook the nation to its
core really and when we understood
that this something very wrong had
happened and we are seeing that kind of
failure
move through every single other issue
that we face in this country that that
was not an accident
that was not a bug it was a feature of
what we are to expect congressman great
job thank you so much i appreciate it
have a very uh good independence weekend
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else